I hold an EPT to Nacional a tiara I told
her well you cannot combine please he
dancer told Morgana that I may see a
trip to Chile's high desert is the
perfect excuse to hang with someone like
Magdalena
she's a shaman who for a reasonable fee
offers up a soul cleanse your spirit is
healed as your brain melts time is an
illusion you know that we all know after
the ceremonial stripping of the gringo
and whatever this is Magdalena forces me
to drink an ungodly amount of water you
will start a new relation with water so
you will be keen alright then she burns
me
into my wounds she pours something
called combo which is a secretion that
comes from a very poisonous
Amazonian tree frog it's done don't
expect anything okay just be here
[Applause]
time is an illusion water is life and
that's when the frog juice really kicked
in
there was the desert
it was cruel and then it was kind
there were huge telescopes nestled up
against the heavens there were strange
gurgling pools full of minerals there
was a bustling city and a chair I could
control with my mind
it was a grand vision of what Chile had
to offer and what needed to be
experiment or something like that you so
yeah Silicon Valley may be home to some
of the biggest tech giants in the world
but it's being challenged like never
before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind my name is Ashley Vance
I'm an author and journalist and I'm on
a quest to find the most innovative tech
creations and meet the beautiful freaks
behind them
science says that the Atacama Desert is
the driest place in the world
[Music]
some parts of the desert go hundreds of
years with no rain at all
the desert plateau is about 10,000 feet
above sea level the days run extremely
hot and the nights get extremely cold
it turns out that this hellscape is the
perfect place to build a telescope
between the high altitude and the lack
of moisture in the air the view of the
Stars is practically unobstructed I'm
heading for the Atacama Large millimeter
array aka Alma the largest astronomical
project in the world
but before I go there's something I have
to do hey go to the doctor but this is
step one of the journey to see the giant
telescopes
voilá goes done almost telescopes sit at
nearly 17,000 feet at that altitude bad
things can happen to the human body like
swelling of the brain so before you
visit you have to prove that you have
the necessary Constitution since I've
spent the past year eating and drinking
as I travel the world unlikely that I
will pass these tests so wish me luck
[Music]
surprisingly enough he's ready to go
change Iowa I pass it's off to the high
desert
so we're just 500 meters now from the
top of the sights you're only allowed to
stay at 5,000 meters for about two hours
I do feel a little bit lightheaded
already
up here it's cold windy and incredibly
hard to breathe
you feel weird in the head and that sort
of adds to the poetry of the place there
are dozens of telescopes and it cost 1.4
billion dollars to build them all here
in the middle of nowhere with the United
States Japan and Europe footing most of
the bill and for that kind of money they
didn't just get a garden-variety optical
telescope they got something special I
tracked down Alma's kindly head mechanic
Fabiola to get a better understanding of
how this place works when you're in
Santiago and you go out to dinner with
somebody how do you explain to them how
the telescope works I'm okay with an
optic telescope you look on the sky and
that's what you see yeah with Alma
whatever you don't see with your eyes
whatever is black that is a lot you see
with Alma Alma sees in what's known as
the millimeter range of the
electromagnetic spectrum far beyond the
visible range seen by optical telescopes
in the human eye armed with this
superhuman vision Alma can unveil all
kinds of magical stuff in the universe
that would have been invisible before
to get an idea of what wonders Alma is
finding in space I went to the control
center where I met this very tall man at
one time when I was in graduate school I
was supposedly the tallest astronomer
who would ever let a younger generation
those taller so I'm not sure that's
still true
Richard Simon and his fellow astronomers
are using Alma to look for the origins
of stars life in the universe itself
with Alma they're able to see the cosmos
in more detail than ever before what I
was looking at the work that you guys do
you could spot even a sugar molecule
near a star that's somewhere off in the
Milky Way we can detect all kinds of
different molecules and think of Alma's
a huge chemical sniffer so we can start
to understand how stars form how planets
form how did we wind up with water to
support life the surreal images Alma
creates have revealed earth-like
exoplanets a comet nursery and galaxies
at the edge of the known universe
[Music]
in the not-so-distant future they can
also help answer the question of whether
we're not alone one of the small moons
of Saturn and philetus has geysers of
water vapor and other materials coming
out and it's possible with all one to
actually look at that and try to see
some of the chemistry that's going on
what is inside that moon
what is blasting out into space are
there complicated organic molecules I
suspect that we will learn a lot more
about the chemistry of life and the
possibilities for life in very strange
places even here on our own solar system
if Alma is an astronomers dream come
true it's also a normal person's worst
nightmare to keep the telescope's
running 24 hours a day all main Ian's
take turns sleeping in these tiny
depressing rooms where they have to live
on site for 8 days at a time
between the thin atmosphere
close-quarters and isolation it's not
unlike living on Mars head engineer
Serge Cunha has been here for two and a
half years and he's seen firsthand the
emotional and physical toll this place
can take it's much more than just
working together you are really on the
same boat if you're looking for a quiet
job with your family going every evening
back home you do not choose this kind of
jobs what does your body feel like after
doing this for a couple of years it's a
price to pay yeah it's it's not a very
healthy altitude your judgment is
heavily altered and you have to be
extremely careful actually we have a
niche last last month one of the guys
were working and he kind of forgot
everything so we immediately bring to
the hospital to get checked his brain
and everything he was okay but we don't
understand what happened to him he was
like who are you it's gotta be Friday I
wasn't you know so scary
do you have really to like it I mean why
do you practice mountaineering yeah why
putting yourself in danger or yourself
in a very in comfortable position for
what so the profile of the guys is a
little bit special strong characters
generally and people motivated by things
which are a little bit different
[Music]
as an astronomer I still have my sense
of wonder when I walk outside like I did
last night and see the stars here and
we're in the Atacama Desert so they're
really bright and close it blows me away
at the same time I'm fortunate to be
able to see the detailed science that
goes on as we tease out that the secrets
of the universe it's hard to predict
what unexpected things we will see in
these distant galaxies the universe that
we see is stranger than we can imagine
[Music]
traversing Chile's high desert is tough
a task for vicunas not humans
then there are plenty of reminders of
just how hostile this land is when you
come to the Atacama Desert one of the
things that you just can't miss are
these sort of beautiful shrines that are
all across the road they're tributes to
people who've died driving on the
highway the long stretches of road the
altitude takes its toll on people the
man that died here was 29 years old
some people survived either by the grace
of God or through dumb luck like these
two dudes who drove their truck off the
road what were you guys doing out here
una mala suerte de padre de sibour que
estaba a regressive OC economy o SE
quedó d'Or me o no
[Music]
it's not all near-death experiences and
sadness out here there's big tech and
big fun to be had as well and to find
the fun you just need to look for the
oasis the town of San Pedro de Atacama
this is one of the world's most remote
tourist hotspots
a magnet for dirty hippies and
chilled-out dogs why would anyone choose
to vacation at 8000 feet in the desert
well there are glorious geysers that
demand to be roamed there are sand dunes
to surf and there are huge watering
holes that no one can explain
[Music]
oddly enough there's big business out in
the atacama too more solar radiation
reaches this desert than anywhere else
in the world this makes it the perfect
place to build massive solar panel farms
if you stop by for a visit
they'll put you to work washing the Pens
that's my technique it's good
the tricky thing about solar energy is
that it needs to be stored like that and
the Atacama happens to have an answer
for that too
Chile is one of the world's leading
producers of lithium the stuff that goes
into all of our smartphone laptop and
electric car batteries but to see how
lithium is pulled from the earth I went
to visit the operations of the mining
Giants sqm hello Ashley how you doing
finally here my guide through the mines
is Alejandro butch err
he's a cheerful engineer who has spent
years working in the great void when I
think of something like a lithium-ion
battery in a laptop or even a Tesla with
thousands of batteries it's what like a
spoonful of lithium that would go into
those batteries you would say now an
iPad or in a cell phone you can have
something like a spoonful in a car you
could have maybe 10 to 15 kilos of
lithium it's the nearby Andes Mountains
that make these mines possible over
millions of years minerals from the
mountain is leaching to the ground then
they collect together and form huge
solvents rich in lithium sulfate
potassium and boron companies like sqn
pump water up through the beds and store
the mineral rich liquid in large ponds
from there it's up to the Sun to do its
thing and evaporate away the water
leaving the minerals and salt behind and
nowhere evaporates better than Chile
now we are heading for the first part of
the pond operation there's a lot of pods
those are pretty this is the first point
you can see the salts forming in the
surface we got salt parking spaces
that's gonna be crazy because you
already have the harsh heat and cold and
then you have all this salt just pour
here on this pickup truck suffer a lot
but the other equipment we made them
from a special steel that really works
good here and now we're moving to the
leeching points that are only two of the
44 million square meters that we have
here this one we made it so we can
experience what is a little brain
when we have it in the big pond we we
cannot sample it so we made this little
pump
what exactly is Vista this is magnesium
koi magnesium chloride
it's a magnesium that we need to get rid
of for being able to produce the lesion
in the plant okay we will only send on
the track the liquid just the liquid
just the lipid okay so this is lithium
what are the odds that some part of this
is in my smartphone I couldn't guarantee
it but it's pretty sure that almost
hundred percent sure that part of your
mud phone went through this pond at some
point that's a must at some point this
is smartphone smartphone juice wow you
guys must be excited that Tesla's are
selling well and that everybody is
getting into soccer cars now
it's very interesting but it it puts a
lot pressure on us so we will more than
double our capacity probably in four
years
chillie may have the largest lithium
deposits in the world but it started to
fall behind countries like Australia and
China when it comes to production and in
China it's a one-stop shop with the
mining and battery production happening
together this is a leap Chilean
companies have been unwilling to take
maybe you could make the batteries here
in Chile well for me it would be
excellent but the company we're experts
in hybrid ology works for the mining
worth reading producing lithium if we
put us to produce batteries we're
probably not going to do it well things
have been extra tense lately between the
mines and the Chilean government the
feds have put strict quotas on lithium
production and they've also been trying
to act tough in save face after some
politico's were accused of taking bribes
from the mines
[Music]
environmentalists are huge fans of the
mines either they say that water is
being sucked from nearby lagoons that
feed these flocks of stunning flow
meters what we do here has absolutely no
impact to the flamingos
but we're still responsible what's
happening with them we need to do
counting of the flamingos every year
they identify them by the furthest on
the tail so they can even check every
flamingo the miners here work for a week
and then take a week off because of the
dry hot salty conditions but there are
some on-the-job perks this sunsets here
are everyday amazing you have all these
different colors that only women know
the names could happen every day and you
don't get tired of that it's really
beautiful
[Music]
alejandra has a point not so much about
the colors that only women apparently
know but about the beauty of the mines
these odd marvels make the modern world
run let Tesla's flamingos breeding
program begin
[Music]
after spending a day being caked in salt
I returned to San Pedro de Atacama
feeling a kinship with cured beats
everywhere speaking of meat this was my
chance to dine on llama tacos for llamo
if you want to sound slightly less like
a gringo kanita llamo taco what's good
[Music]
we've got all this delicious sauce in
here I think that llaman tacos they're
gonna be the next big thing in Silicon
Valley for sure
[Music]
Gillian's like to hold Santiago up is a
symbol of everything they've done right
it's orderly and prosperous and there's
all that you would want from a capital
city clinging to the bottom of the globe
[Music]
sure you can get roped into the
occasional Ngati kuri but here they say
it's more refined and nothing says
refinement like a footlong Coney
mayonnaise definitely possible choice
[Music]
this capital built with mineral wealth
and struggling with its fallout is
looking for new ways to survive in a
changing environment
[Music]
yo en dia totin cuenta con que cambiar
chromatic Oh until a al menos effect ow
la condicional de optician de agua
Julius annulus on dude
yes agua de calidad general I went to
him from another gun so actor Pino
figured out how to make water from air
with the touch of a button
Hector made a fortune as an engineer but
now works full-time on his fresh water
system what propelled you to think up
this project plan fer Miami huh yeah
Dana Segundo Malcolm he need o aloof
when you're a investigan donate a mundo
and elastin ogia vm o que hay una de
Gracia Milla Dodd caso de listen tanky
son Marino's Debussy probably fig a
Kalia
yes a tango he approaches 10 un mundo
muy into t al-assad ya lo in for motto
domestic obereg mija boy Alex eres es
agua que le man to hear a la Sol an
asana two years dismiss en el home yeah
okay en you dare Jesus de severe a ah
que complete my family Ananya ECC eighty
on okay de una yeah normal actor sees
des technology having uses far beyond
his family this freshwater machine feeds
off humidity in the air it pulls in
water particles through a vent and then
basically forms a rain cloud inside the
machine a series of filters purify the
water collect it and then pristine h2o
flows out of the fuss
[Music]
so I can drink it yeah yo baby we'll
have eternity it's not problem we
delicioso
how I like it right now one magic water
machine cost about 1,600 bucks but he
wants to shrink the price and its size
to something like a backpack as he
perfects the design he's installed as
machines in chillies dry north locate
Amazon Dora
Tommo million Doel impacto por que una
cosa int'l a la tecnología pero la otra
saber bueno Scipio
well fue la consecuencia yes impacto
sociologic oh yay oh no miko el que Tom
Oh Millie endo para poder nosotros calar
a say Auto paisa motor a - bueno
resultado actually distilled the idea
for fresh water inside an incubator
funded by some of Santiago's wealthiest
people it's called the idea factory for
if for those into the whole brevity
thing they support tech with a do-gooder
bent politicians stop by to schmooze
kids get a chance to learn it's not a
factory designed to build the next
Google or Facebook
it focuses on things for Chile in South
America and they've got hyper local
branches hidden in unexpected corners of
Santiago there are tech incubators all
over the world but you won't find many
in a neighborhood like this if has
another building here that's been set up
to inspire local youngsters and give
budding inventors a helping hand
here in recoleta things are a bit more
lively than in palo alto and it suits
the place I showed up on a demo day when
kids from the neighborhood pour through
the gates to check out if schedules
there was plenty of eye candy but
nothing beat this hello
robots it's like every other video
conferencing robot on a stick but this
one is basically leaf
[Music]
that's so cool all of the gadgets come
from this man
rodrigo Quevedo he's something of a
local celebrity and has kanye west's
levels of passion Quon le memo for so
lemme Mogra zone : Mattel agencia vamos
algo odyssia padamu tose aquí la
llevamos alguien ariados tiene sólo que
mal necesita lo que no se puede oír lo
que no Mombasa Verna bueno
abbiamo a loop a case a New Haven can
say Mo's Osceola Cedar Valley yeah
Rodrigo was an officer in the Chilean
army and then an engineer until he had a
revelation and became a robotics
entrepreneur his most inspired invention
is this wheelchair people can control it
by tilting their head or making a
gesture soon Roderigo hopes it'll move
by thought alone by reading impulses
from a brainwave monitor I want to get
up to understand see familiar
Oh des Thomas n dodo mucho más pequeño
yeah tell the mayor my lawful Sheila
Rodriguez helpers were surprisingly
gentle as they gave me the power of
telekinesis it but is and there is it
Emma
that's how I turn it on three blinks I
say it's like a genie foot then you know
those Kris oh my god
[Music]
that's crazy it's amazing I see with
great power comes great hunger and
superheroes need super food
[Music]
and for that I had to travel an hour
outside Santiago to the San Bernardo
region in Chile's world-famous wine
country
put down that acai goji mangosteen
kombucha and say hello to Mackey berry
[Music]
Mackey has been around for centuries
it's a super berry the native people of
the mapuche tribes have known this for
centuries this is my friend Bors Irma's
he's the owner of south am free stride
where you guessed it they freeze dry and
packaged tasty fruits and vegetables
including the Mackey berry when the
superfood searchers and the scientists
discovered the Maggie what were the
properties that they discovered compared
to other super foods they realize that
Mackey has a very very high antioxidant
count which is just you know really off
the charts to see how the Mackey makes
its way from the tree to an overpriced
cleanse Boris took me on a tour of the
factory so about to go into the actual
food part and we need to suit up after
transforming into two very hip lunch
ladies it was time to go inside we're
looking good and we're set man okay
let's go through his weight okay
this is where the process starts
we free said in a previous facility it's
brought here so we need to raise the
temperature of it wash it take outs
order all the leaves the twigs
everything after the berries warm up
they need to get cold again so they're
wheeled into a giant freezer after a few
hours
they're then wheeled into what's called
the freeze tunnel where they stay for
about 24 hours
as the tunnel sucks away all of their
moisture you basically create on a very
large scale a high vacuum the water
crystal in the food goes from solid into
gas state without going through the
liquid see preserving the nutritional
value of the food the Bors didn't invent
this process far from it
you obviously have all this modern
equipment but you were saying in South
America some of these techniques
actually go back hundreds of years it is
said that the Incas discovered a way to
free try the fruit given the high
altitude in the mountains that would
have a lighted pressure because of the
atmosphere which is what basically we do
with the tunnels and you have extreme
changes of temperature and then back in
the 50s
NASA refined the process to create what
is known today as Austrian food which is
using all sorts of things
finally it was time for the most
important step the taste test we have
here Maki very blueberry pineapple and
banana powder to prepare smooth in your
honor you see how the purple overcomes
everything
so let's give it a try okay
churches salute still left I am look at
our lips it looks like lipstick that's a
nice color on you I saw the value and
freeze-drying
the food gives it is fun it's crunchy
it's different too much your ID it does
look like you consume a lot of water
when you could just flexibly off the
tree we try to be efficient with it
we're basically what you're taking out
is the water that the produce itself has
we recycle that water heating the
tunnels with warm water we've tried to
make it efficient with the micro
turbines so we try to balance it all and
keep our carbon path alone
Boris has already started selling the
Maki powder around the world for use in
smoothies and supplements may we all
have purple lips and live forever
[Music]
chillie will always have a special place
in my subconscious when I close my eyes
at night I can still hear my shaman
Magdalena singing and see her desert
compound she scarred me but you know in
a good way of all my trips around the
world this year this one was a proper
adventure there's a mystical quality to
Chile
it only gets more profound as your body
dries out and your brain loses oxygen
that's for the tech Chile has the big
stuff down
it has embraced the weirdness of the
land and tried to make the most out of
it
if the startups in Santiago can tap into
that same spirit then Chile has a bright
future ahead either that or the poison
really got
[Music]
you